hey it's me markiplier here with a
special message for you have you ever
wanted to be cool well now you can by
going to markiplier comm slash live and
watching the live stream to the
Environmental Defense Fund if you do you
will guaranteed be 200% cooler by the
end of the fiscal year and then you can
tell all your friends of which you'll
have after you get friends because
you're cooler and then you'll come to
the live stream where you'll be embraced
money from the Environmental Defense
Fund and then you'll have all the
friends you could possibly want but no
one will question your sanity so come on
down to the screen have a good time for
friendly people